this is Samsung t9000 refrigerator it's
a smart refrigerator with 32 cubic feet
and 3 climate zones it's got a
refrigerator a freezer and one that's
convertible so you can go either way
refrigerator or freezer based on your
needs but the really neat thing about
this is the built in tablet that's
internet connected it has apps on there
like Evernote so you can build a grocery
list at home and take it with you and
your phone or if you're out and about
and someone is at home they need to pick
up milk or whatever they can add it to
your grocery list it'll automatically
sync to your phone there's a coupon
feature your daily whether it's a really
cool fridge